hallo leute ich jetzt wieder einmal
waren willkommen zu einer neuen folge 5
trinkspiele schon heute hätten wir drei
zusammen trinkt spiele ich hab nämlich
entdeckt dass es auf amazon sehr eine
trinkspiele gibt ich bin da auch nie
gekommen als ring spiele zu suchen aber
es gab schon ein paar spiele machen wir
testen uns einfach durch gewissen die
spiele heute jetzt nicht durch spiele
gespielt wir haben gerade schon drei gut
ist allein gedreht wurde
das ist hier ein bisschen ausgerottet
haben wir an mit dem ersten spiel unser
erstes training spiel was ich raus
gesucht habe interessiert mich sehr
die idee hatte ich hab gedacht ich
bringe meins trinkt bier ausgeschenkt zu
einem trinkspiel machen das ist einfach
zu spielen und das gespann jane hat die
klötzchen rausziehen ja dann stehen da
sachen auch nicht so gut ich kann den
ganzen tag jeden tag kinderspiel
also wieso gibt es noch dran kennen es
ist doch krank ist wir haben hier ein
holzblock der guten mit klassik einfach
das was mich interessiert ist ob man zu
gut spielen kann das tränken aufstellen
direkt ausstellungen weg aufstellen ja
was soll betroffene trauen
denker regeln man muss ja raus ziehen
und wieder neben die drauflegen lesen
machen drauf bin drauf legen wir dann
sind nicht okay wäre dann schon was
morgen mehr
das ist zwar nicht bescheuert oder
schädigt drauf filmproduktion
wegschmeißen und dann hat glück gehabt
oder ihr glück gehabt ich muss nichts
drin das ist übrigens der kern von
trinkspielen leute sagen ach glück
gehabt ich muss nichts trinken in den
mittleren nichts
russian standard vodka es dann machen
wir das immer schwieriger
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die mauer nun besinnen da ist aber kein
echter alkohol das macht dieses würde
hätte ich machen dass wir hier in the
fly während problem
und nachdem wir drei cocktails die
bba'ler gedreht haben als echten alkohol
benutzen würden dass wir absolut finde
ich auch hier weiß kassel außerdem stehe
es schon jetzt schon krank ist also es
ist das erste spiel und wenn ich jetzt
hier wird die no punkte vergeben müsste
und jeder punkt sieht aus wie ein
anderer die nung damit man es sich zu
einfach hat beim schneiden und dann will
ich da höre ich auf jeden fall ein
achtel video punkt einfach geben aber
von einem tyrannosaurus rex aber nur
dass man die fläche nun dass man
nebenbei kamen sie und ganz irgendwo auf
dem screen ihren das will ich dem geben
das ist mir nichts wert also das ist
enttäuschend dass mit der abzocke nicht
üblich bitte des horns von einem einbaum
ok und nicht nur züge dem als ein spaß
und ich würde sagen ich liebe kann man
sieben züge eigentlich muss sage ich bin
also echt verhandelt school die spitze
des ein wort das war schon ziemlich viel
das ja schon ziemlich viel spaß
kommen wir zum nächsten spiel ich würde
sagen mach mit dem spiel weiter und mich
lächelt gerade wegen dem einhorn der
unicorn express an einem engen schwarz
aber die regenbogenfarben da ist dieses
spiel wie für dich gemacht ja der
kartenstapel wird gemischt und kommt in
die mitte das jüngste 1 haben beginnt
und zieht eine karte
danach wird reihum jeweils pro einwohner
eine karte gezogen es gibt zwei
verschiedene karten ab es ist eine
studie next nike denkt die eine regel
aus
diese wird in die mitte gelegt und gilt
für alle oder sich geil
das sind im prinzip wie die man trinken
muss muss man noch mal trinken
nein es ist ich finde es eine tolle
regel weil trinkspiel am liebsten schon
sehr toll und wenn man die auch noch
verdoppelt denn es ist doch doppelt
soviel sprach in der welt führen
vorgespräche führen bei den leuten
ok ja ich das geht so nächste karte
wörter kette diejenige die diese karte
gezogen habt gibt ein wort vor danach
muss immer weiter ein wort angefügt
werden falls das letzte wort weder
sinnvoll noch kreativ ist muss diejenige
trinken wie es gesagt hat fünf insassen
des sexistisch ist ja nur für frauen ist
die jungs das geht ich will hier haltung
sozialismus cbs halterung mechanismus
ende
das wars das ist musste treten anleitung
der olga doppelt eineinhalb ich glaube
an das zitat du wirst nie besiegen
alle schokoladenliebhaber rinnen treten
ich lege diese karten verdeckt im
verteidigungs- modus aber du bist dran
ziehen
bitte vervollständigen den satz trinke
wenn die scheinheiligen auf die das
zutrifft trinkt rebellen du schon mal
geatmet hast wahrscheinlich gerieten
verstärkt die miss teen kann wählt eine
mitspielerin die drei schlucke trinkt du
wärst arthur wetzel vanessa richtung
und mit dem trinken und trifft jeder
muss einen reim zu dem von dir
vorgegebenen worten diejenige der
sternchen derjenige die als erste in den
städten erster zu lange zögert oder
einen rein doppelt nennt schöner stellt
trinkt maus rausschmiss braucht klaus
dürfen nahmen nun ja das hätte ich auch
jetzt gesagt 123 und roger treece möchte
diese karte kaufen wir waren es - wegen
einer wurst
ich bin gerade wenn thierse ich hab auch
videofilme warten verharrt brachten ist
alter juni power paar teile drei stücke
freuen wenn dieses spiel ich habe keinen
bock mehr nehmen
wir ziehen das durch partei die drei
stücke die den 123 maria zum glück hatte
muss am 4
eine regel das hast du die regelleistung
erfunden sternenstaub drei karten und
verteilte diese an deine mitspieler
jenner sternchen regenbogen du darf eine
regel karte rauswerfen
werfe die doppel treten karte raus das
siegel ist alles getrieben man von
dezember 2007 das weiß ja keiner
wir haben anscheinend bisher mit
jemandem zusammen oder vielleicht auch
nicht nötig ihren nämlich nicht ein
wahlgesetz denke die eine regel aus
und jetzt kaufen bevor wir etwas noch
nicht wieder richtig fit sein bevor
wieder bevor wir einen trinken deswegen
müssen wir eine runde spielen das muss
es passieren bevor wir trinken muss man
immer aufstehen und studio absagen
einfach nur vor jedem schluck dem antrag
auch wenn man es trinke ich gut das
nächste wunder allerdings rand maulkorb
niemand darf mehr ich du und sie dann
das findet man cool welche würde wieder
kann man vielleicht nicht betrieben
hockey los geht's weiter kommt noch eine
runde wie spiel hundert wenn ich möchte
auch noch eine frontpartie alle träger
promit schülerin einschlug
jede die eine schwester hat trinken
ich möchte sagen das ist ein echt fanny
spiel führt gerade auch wenn man das mit
kern spielt weil es so ein bisschen
dieses fanny und ja aber das mit dem
sinn macht furchtbar
also bei mir sind es sind es vier von
fünf linken augen punkt es ist kannst du
nicht einmal bewertung warum warum peter
5 4 sternen ach so wie ich bin deutsch
und ich gib mir fünf sterne auf der hand
drauf
ich gebe fünf von handtüchern ich liebe
auch von den wichtigsten wörter sagen
die gäste jetzt sagen wir gar nichts und
dann eben spiel ist klink oppoli
sportspaß cottbus zwar bereit wenn das
jetzt monopoly ist los so regeln karten
dann bin ich richtig dabei
das ist ein 4,5 für mich aber selbst
gesprochen das geld 12 trinke einen
kurzen kommt ich glaube ich einen kurzen
gut ist ein kurssprung dass es doch
machen wir so ein casino 2
[Gelächter]
oder gehen bereit
gerade mal was komme ich auch mit 2,34
den leuten gesagt die tiere eine
bekannte person wäre sie erkennt trinkt
nicht 234 gehe 13 23 karte hat sie ein
witz die mitglieder werden entscheiden
aber gut genug war damit nicht einen
kurzen trip war jetzt kommt das publikum
kommt eine frau beim arzt ok schade es
war schwierig macht echt spaß lade einen
mitspieler auf ein date ein er sie wird
entscheiden ob du einen kurzen trinken
muss arthur wirst du willst du mit mir
mal vielleicht eine bar gehen
du hast einen freund
[Musik]
[Applaus]
212 trinke mit beiden nachbarn ihr seid
meine nachbarn über messer 3 schlug 6 1
2 3 4 5 6
wir müssen ein bisschen die dinger durch
ya konan 1 234 behle wer mit dir einen
kurzen training nicht mal was sagt
einfüllen einstige kommt ein spieler auf
dieses feld trinken alle spieler
ich kann nicht mehr stehen 42 43 46 der
jüngste trinkt einen schluck und trinke
die anzahl an schlucken die du hast also
das was wir drauf stehen muss man es
sagen 344 schlückchen let's go papa
macht sie durch jetzt drei treffer war
ein spiel auf diesem feld muss er sich
entscheiden ob er zwei kurze trinkt oder
sich bis auf die unterwäsche ausziehen
zu verkürzen
das ganze glas
[Applaus]
das video nimmt sind ganze drei mal
sitzt hier im dorf lassen und so im stil
von ist sie seit beweise dich im
armdrücken mit dem führer denn der
verlierer trinkt nein
ok machst countdown 3 2 3 2 1
an ihrer trinkt ja
kokettieren besseren winkel das gibt
dann genau so stellt sich komplett
rheintal ist besser dass du jetzt gewinn
ausweisen
aber sie hatte jetzt in den starken
partners weg jetzt noch keine karte
der gentleman würde gewinnen lassen aber
in der theke ich gerade stehe da gibt es
keine sieger merken lassen und lasst
doch einfach das free spielt aber
anstatt die karten von denen man die
unicorn kaan ok dran bleiben hier darauf
hängen das ist doch eine chance
irgendwer denn da drauf damit endlich
mal ausziehen zu können
warum sieht man warum zum beispiel ein
trinkspiel einfach nur weil leute wollen
ja und wenn man will dass die anderen
heute danken der triumphale der seit 40
jahren trinkspiele spielen alles schon
gesehen ausgezogen sind dann geht alles
schnell ein bisschen ich bin hier wurde
gefahrene trinke einen schluck und
würfel doch einmal dieses spiel nicht
wir müssen eben weiter 26 passt nicht
einmal 1 2 3 4 5 6 3
also wir müssen ins spiel bewertung
machen 55 und eingeschlossen ich habe
lange nicht mehr so viel gelacht ich bin
auch nicht für das kommt wirklich darauf
an mit wem man spielt ja spielt mit 5
und 5 mit den richtigen leuten ich fand
dieses spiel
es war sehr ich liefere folglich kann
man nicht mal ändern weil ich so gelacht
hat die tun ja was lagern den richtigen
leuten richtig
klatsch geschichte erzählen
[Musik]